bonsoir à kader abderrahim merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france les
enjeux de cette poursuite de la
coopération militaire russo turque
quelles sont elles il s'agit de trouver
des points de convergence des intérêts
communs qui peuvent exister
éventuellement entre la russie et la
turquie sur le dossier liban libye
pardon comme comme les les russes et les
turcs avaient trouvé des points de
convergence sur d'autres théâtres
d'autres conflits notamment je pense à
la à la syrie aujourd'hui à marc
desplats mangeot stratégique à la fois
que turcs et russes en méditerranée et
l'enjeu est considérable
il s'agit peut-être pour ces deux
puissances nous aujourd'hui de trouver
les voies et les moyens d'être
durablement des partenaires et des
interlocuteurs des européens ce qui
jusqu'à présent étaient plutôt mal perçu
pas à bruxelles je parle quand je dis
bruxelles je parle de l'europe
évidemment et surtout qui était très mal
perçu parce que les russes comme les
turcs étaient à la perception qu'on
pouvait en avoir
du côté européen c'était plutôt celle
d'avoir affaire à des adversaires plutôt
qu'à des partenaires qu'est-ce que cela
dit justement la poursuite de cette
coopération militaire russo turque sur
l'étape des relais ce de la relation
bilatérale parce qu'on sait que ce sont
vous l'avez dit des partenaires
notamment dans le cadre de médiations
c'est le cas en syrie oui en effet bon
alors c'est toujours extrêmement
compliqué parce qu' il peut y avoir des
convergences mais il peut y avoir aussi
des divergences et je crois que cette
rencontre à ce niveau ministériel entre
les deux chefs de la diplomatie des
diplomaties mutuaide de l'ain de la
russie et de la turquie sont faits pour
tenter d'aplanir les divergences qui
pourraient se faire jour
donc je crois qu'il s'agit surtout
aujourd'hui de trouver les moyens de
s'installer durablement en méditerranée
de manière à être des puissances
incontournable et à être des
interlocuteurs pour l'heure
ob qu'ils ne peuvent plus faire en
méditerranée comme si ces deux pays
n'existait pas et donc je crois que
c'est ça la grande nouveauté on attend
on voit assez bien les contours des
projets turcs et russes
et aujourd'hui on attend toujours de
voir et de comprendre éventuellement ce
que pourrait être le projet européen sur
la méditerranée alors il est comment va
réagir l'otan justement on rappelle
quand même que la turquie est un membre
un pays membre de l'alliance atlantique
oui écoutez je veux pas ici tourner le
couteau dans la plaie en rappelant ce
qu'a dit emmanuel macron le président
français lui même le temps est en état
de mort cérébrale
donc sans aller aussi loin je crois que
l'otan qui a été le bras armée
occidentale pendant toute la période de
la guerre froide doit aujourd'hui revoir
sa position sur un certain nombre de
dossiers notamment puisque c'est ce qui
nous intéresse ce soit sur la question
de l'hygiène et la méditerranée
parce que c'est vrai que disait sergueï
lavrov il ya un instant les occidentaux
ont une lourde responsabilité dans la
situation actuelle en libye et que donc
il me semble qu'il faut aujourd'hui
trouver d'autres partenaires pour tenter
de stabiliser la situation
parce que c'est un c'est l'intérêt de
tout le monde
la libé étape et en méditerranée mais il
est également et peut-être même surtout
avant tout un pays au maghreb et on a
durablement par l'intervention militaire
de 2011 déstabiliser le maghreb
il faudrait lui redonner de la stabilité
et donc favorisées et sur la libye qui
étaient étaient au coeur des échanges
également de cette rencontre vous pensez
qu'on pourrait diriger vers une
nouvelle médiation avec peut-être
l'implication de la russie en libye
rapidement
écoutez il me semble qu'elle est déjà
très très impliquée je vois pas ce
qu'elle pourrait faire de plus si ce
n'est favoriser le dialogue interlibyen
et permettre d'aboutir un véritable
agenda calendrier électoral après qu'il
y est eu un compromis politique entre la
cyrénaïque et la tripolitaine sur un
agenda commun et des institutions qui
permettent enfin de redonner à la libye
toute sa légitimité dans le concert des
nations
merci beaucoup kader abderrahim je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
recherche à l'ibf